gift of nil gift of old bless the  righteousness guide my hand against the  darkness my final stand  Barbara I want to get to know you a  little bit more you have many friends  where by your sister I play your dragons  or whatever if you ask me to code be  hilarious what are you doing  what's at home there's some serious  stuff going down  I find Giants I hunt you I killed Giants  cool yeah that's it dark omens are  totally cool  a giant comes in place and takes  everything from you and when it's done  it's like anything that made your life  good wasn't never even there Giants not  real  [Music]  I know that no one likes me I know that  everything I do looks crazy  this isn't real we're gonna save this  town  [Music]  there are times where you have to ask  yourself so I want to live my life is a  coward or a warrior  you  [Music]  you